[Music]
nora is on a trek
but her trekking plants are short-lived
as on the way
she is captured by the villagers now to
escape from them
nora has to complete a task given to her
failing which she will be imprisoned for
life
scary right let's see what happened
to give her the task a villager takes
nora to a dark room
she's told that there are two benches on
one bench there are 50 coins
while none on the second as usual
both sides of the coins are not the same
in this case
one side is painted in yellow while the
other in white
now the coins are placed such that
exactly 20 coins have yellow side facing
up
now the task given to her is that she
has to move the coins from bench one to
bench two
such that both the benches would have
the same number of coins
with the yellow side facing up the total
number of coins on both the benches
need not be the same the only task
is to have an equal number of yellow
side facing up coins
on both sides sounds difficult isn't it
will nora be able to crack it let's find
out
hey this is ganesh here from don't
memorize before we get to the solution
of this riddle
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and hit the bell icon
so that you never miss a video from us
okay back to where we left off
nora first tries to have a look at the
coins but the room
is so dark that the coins are not
clearly visible
when she feels the coins she realizes
that the textures of both the sides are
the same
so no luck here as well at this moment
it looks as if nora will be stuck with
the villagers forever
too soon to judge nora actually
completes the task
and gains her freedom but how exactly
did she solve it
why don't you pause the video and try
solving it by yourself
for the strategy that led nora to the
answer keep watching the video
now nora knows that there must be a
concrete strategy to solve the puzzle
hence instead of devising strategy for
50 coins
she starts thinking about a small sample
size of two coins
so she considers only two coins to be on
bench one
one coin with yellow side facing up and
second with
white side facing up now she thinks that
if she moves
any of the two coins to bench two then
the number of coins with the yellow side
facing up
would be unequal on both the benches
she thinks for a while and the only
solution she comes up with is to flip
the coin when moving it to the next
table
only then can she be certain that she
will have an equal number of coins with
yellow side facing up
which is zero and one in possibilities
one and two respectively
wow nora feels that she has some
breakthrough
but when it comes to solving a logical
puzzle she knows that it's important to
look at as many possibilities as
possible
so she now assumes bench one to have two
coins with yellow side facing up
if she moves one coin to bench two she
wouldn't obtain the desired answer
even if she flips it before placing in
the last possibility she had obtained
the result when she moves just one coin
okay so she now thinks what if she moves
both the coins
if she places them without flipping them
again she wouldn't obtain the result
but flipping them both before placing
onto bench two
will definitely give her the desired
outcome
so flipping the coins is a part of the
trick
but what else needs to be noticed here
think about it can she randomly flip any
number of coins
it hits nora that the strategy seems to
work only when the number of coins
flipped
are equal to the number of coins with
yellow side facing up
but our smart nora won't jump to
conclusions too soon
to validate whether the strategy would
work every time
nora takes a slightly higher number five
coins
she randomly assumes one coin to have
yellow side facing up
and the other four coins to have white
side facing up
here she needs to ascertain that the
flipping trick works
so she takes one random coin see the one
with the yellow side up
and assumes to flip it and place it on
bench too
what do you think would be the outcome
that is correct
on both the benches there would be zero
coins with yellow side facing up
okay now she moves a coin with the white
side facing up
and flips it while placing it on bench
two
wow she realizes that here too the
strategy works
that is both the benches would have an
equal number of coins with the yellow
side facing up
amazing this result is obtained
when she assumes just one yellow side
facing up coin
but then nora knows that it's important
that she touches upon
every possibility having one yellow side
facing up coin
is one of the possible cases there are
four more
and here they are nora now starts with
the second possibility
that is two yellow side facing up coins
she has to flip and transfer two coins
to the next bench
first she assumes both the coins to be
with the yellow side facing up
bingo after flipping both sides would
have no coins with the yellow side
facing up
okay now she looks at the second
possibility
where she would move one yellow side
facing up coin and one white side facing
up coin
if she flips both the coins and places
them on bench two
then the result obtained would be
totally in her favor
one coin each of yellow side facing up
on both the benches
well this looks good isn't it
now for the last possibility where both
the coins are white sided facing up
now if nora flips them and moves them to
bench 2
then what would be the result correct
both benches would have two coins with
yellow side facing up
eureka moment having dealt with two
possible cases
nora moves on to the third case where
the number of yellow side facing up
coins are three
and the number of white side facing up
coins are two
she establishes that there can only be
these three possibilities
nora begins with the first possibility
assuming she gets hold of one yellow
side facing up coin
and two white side facing up coins if
she flips
and moves them to bench two then it will
change to two yellow side facing up
coins
and one white side facing up coin
now the number of yellow side facing up
coins would be two
on each bench nora moves on to the
possibility too
two yellow side facing up coins and one
white side facing up coin
if she flips them and moves then again
both the benches would have equal number
of yellow side facing up coins
that is one bingo
nara now goes to a certain the third
possibility where nora takes all the
coins which are yellow side facing up
when she flips and moves them all the
coins change to white side facing up
coins on the next bench
which means both the benches have equal
number of coins with the yellow side
facing up
that is zero eureka
nura also checks for the last two
possible cases applying the same
strategy
and the outcome is exactly what she had
expected
why don't you try for these two possible
cases and share your findings with us
so here nora has established a foolproof
strategy
where the major role is played by the
number of coins with the yellow side up
on bench one
she just needs to think about the number
of coins with yellow side up
and randomly flip only those many coins
onto the next bench
and this was the strategy that nora
applied which won her the freedom
does by applying the same strategy to 50
coins
that is by moving 20 coins from bench
one and then flipping them over to bench
two
nora gains her freedom amazing isn't it
take a moment and let that sink in now
before leaving let me shoot yet another
puzzle out here
but remember this one may or may not
follow the logic which we had used to
solve our puzzle
here you go as there was no contact with
nora
zeki sets to find her he also happens to
be captured by the same villagers
and this was the puzzle given to zeki
zeki
has to replace the letters here with the
digits so that the sum here
is true why don't you try to solve the
puzzle
and share your answers in the comment
section
for more interesting puzzles do not
forget to subscribe to our channel